vanessa perotti tuvo una de sus jornadas
laborales más cortas en su carrera ella
se desempeña como secretaria de un
hospital en las afueras de parís y fue
suspendida sin goce de sueldo por no
contar a la fecha con al menos una dosis
de la vacuna contra el cob y 19
estoy disgustada pero no hay algo que
pueda hacer tengo que aguantarlo no sé
qué será mañana sé que no me pagan a
partir de hoy
pero ni but the king es la medida que
fue anunciada hace dos meses por el
presidente en manuel macrón aplica
también para quienes cuidan a personas
vulnerables o de la tercera edad ésta
cuenta con la aprobación del parlamento
y ha generado invitación en un sector de
los trabajadores de la salud quienes han
salido a marchar denunciando una
violación de las libertades individuales
para el gobierno la iniciativa busca
proteger tanto a los trabajadores de la
salud como a la población más frágil la
regla se aplicará a partir de hoy los
trabajadores de la salud que no hayan
recibido una dosis de la vacuna podrán
ser suspendidos por sus empleadores los
que hayan recibido sólo una dosis
tendrán un período de tolerancia hasta
el 15 de octubre para que tengan tiempo
de recibo segunda dosis
no estamos estigmatizando a nadie
estamos responsabilizando a todos esta
medida es necesaria se anunció hace dos
meses y sobre todo es urgente nadie está
más expuesto que un trabajador de la
salud en sueño de acuerdo con cifras
oficiales más del 90 por ciento de los
trabajadores de la salud han sido
vacunados restando cerca de 300.000 sin
inmunización alguna la amenaza de
suspensión eleva la preocupación por un
aumento en la presión sobre el personal
que quede en el sistema sanitario